yellow went and welcome to this video ya
Yin the man playdom ten times ok that is
already quite a bit didn't think it was
all that much but ok let's see with Cory
getting a hedgehog type of position a
six gather a couple of options here a
6-bit should be 76 I'm going for my
favorite set up here with be three this
is something where I believe that
against this particular move order that
white has some chances for a slight edge
check let's see what happens at 95 is a
surprising move because f4 is part of my
agenda anyway aha ok interesting that's
an interesting concept and I mean
interesting yeah really interesting
something sometimes it's kind of yeah
interesting that's an interesting
painting you know I think it's [ __ ]
but I say interesting because I want to
be friendly another thing that's
interesting idea how do I go with oh how
many keep this up for 45 or be 50
interesting maybe maybe here and now
move the night night to eat you or
something yeah okay d 5 is probably a
slight edge I can take f 6 95 HP 5
should be a weakness ok what is he doing
here night c5 know that really doesn't
do all that much I can play Bishop a3
now also yeah this is not bad
ok I think this is rice ok now yet you
form going for going 45 potentially but
now I can take the six right um yeah I
don't I don't see a drawback to taking
he has to be fired that that's probably
and no okay um look to the 19 I can also
go e5 but then f6 I think I'd rather go
here yeah so I can take a 6cm this one
idea or or just 20 just capture the
other ideas to remember it's interesting
93 takes + B form it's a bit of a fancy
way of playing it and it's too fancy for
my taste it's probably not bad
okay d 55 still remains weak so I'm
going to retreat this only six the rook
is not very stable so what do I have
here two minutes 22 minutes 21 so it's a
cert a good amount of time oh wow what
about 35 or what about f5 taking more
space in generally weekends d5 quite a
bit 93 would be great but let's not on
at the moment but this is this is
already kind of worrisome for black
right isn't it light up or look deformed
just ripped it for him attack the pawn
the mini season time claim or no I guess
and he should be a mean I for every
spent quite a bit of time here and for
not all that much I have the same I mean
I have a winning position but I didn't
need to think as long as I did I think
before is dropping now if he tries to
cover it okay maybe can go Ruby 7
imminent and Bagwell f-93 coming up if
he plays a rope to the be far and then
I'll take Lucas III mmmm yeah but now
before us is dropping I think I don't
see how he covers it
the n95 plus looks normal let's cover h
2 Kings you to other room it doesn't
even have many squares available here it
has to go and go all the way back to h6
something something like that okay did I
blunder that I did young blasted winning
fortunately rook c8 and night at five
chick will pick up the h6 book I will
see a 95 and that will be that's winning
check check check so let's see how to
I'm dry blonde at 95 you okay there
wasn't founded still winning with anyway
anyway his night is mostly dominated
here time morning it's an a for
something can't we go gay for clap oh oh
i am not paying any attention which
which is not good
clock definitely should blunder the beep
are now that that that would be really
application yeah night she is checking
me he's got 97 here right amazing
amazing
clock takes root chicks should win and
here will be six is coming ice well he's
now defending this pretty well and I've
got 20 seconds I am made my life really
difficult him clack clack hmm that's
funny across the self-made yeah and i
managed to blunder the beep on great
great great great so now you cannot win
this sometime that that's crazy that's
really crazy yeah I didn't pay any
attention after this game I mean out
again how the game went was like so
one-sided I already didn't didn't pay
any attention which is a problem i know
it happens quite quite frequently I just
sometimes don't don't think cuz I'm oh
yeah what was that game is effectively
over but it is not over especially not
in blitz just check white for fix on
time yeah ok that's ready check check
check the whole table 6 trillion inside
I just I just got it to my pay no
attention mode which is so I don't
really know I don't really know what to
do about it I mean he writes to me Roxy
several as a blunder yeah of course I
mean he gave away the t61 it's the whole
game is basically a blunder by black I
mean what's the what's the problem here
I mean
cannot give away and they have porn or
delivers and also check complete win
again probably check from probably
window multiple ways now just bring the
king over push the palms or something
like that check ya at he had 95 here but
Joe I think this ending is so many even
after buggering the exchange and yeah
yes I just blood with both crowns and
then at the end I mean it's still
winning check check check know by now it
is so it's reasonably truly and it's a
strong I mean he found the only moves
that make some kind of yeah this is this
is not enough three not in not Luke age
for something you always have to be
careful now with the with the folks
check and I know yeah this is crazy
right yeah I can I can run another check
mate technique yeah this is this is this
is funny and yeah so yeah but okay
otherwise okay so i had to do this this
ending is a draw but I have 16 seconds I
mean this is impossible to do in 16
seconds I I cannot get both cars it's a
problem I mean holding it is certainly
easy to just run in the front of the
pawns but I try to to get the pawns to
make it with the time yeah you can
always just shuffle around doing nothing
and went on time so I try to somewhat
get to this appointment okay it was it
was in vain and probably deserved I mean
and I have this problem really that if
the game is a completely one-sided
affair like this one sometimes just off
I think okay this will win itself
basically and yeah then time ticks down
and okay I'm I'm really bad I really bad
and this is regard like he five resins
and so on there are tons of tons of
simpler wins but somehow I
have this brain shut down sometimes that
and I think okay why is this game even
going on anymore and I'm just really not
paying attention and I don't know ever
way of it it's not like I'm not aware of
it but I somehow cannot get rid of this
in the games I don't know what it is
I've had this in tournament games but
this is bad this is over now I mean in
tournament games I I don't have that
problem anymore but in blitz it still
happens very frequently especially does
that is the game is so one sided I mean
the end Black is just tortured from the
get-go he wrote me some some messages he
should be able to load this blah blah
blah it's possible yeah but you're still
getting completely tortured in this
position and of course this is making it
very easy for what but those super one
sided games I tend to really not think
at one point and think okay or whatever
yeah why is he wasting time by
continuing to play with okay of course
it can't play on and as we have seen if
I'm playing I can completed yet can you
can order Sam I mean at least he had a
draw on the project we need one time is
another matter but I really don't know
what it is what did I spent the vast
amount of time you by the way I would
like you to know that I spent some time
here actually why did I spend time away
I spend to come over anything he played
instant groups all the way I told he had
the crap position as it usually happens
so that was also an issue I mean he's
played like immediately every move so
this also costs a bit of time because I
cannot think and commentate on on his
time but ok this is all of the not the
issue i just have to continue to play
chess after getting the completely a
winning position yeah i mean i know i
know the issue but i am ASO and sit
happens it still happens and i'm not
quite sure what to do about it anyway
thanks for watching